Steven Ogg, the guy who plays Negan's brutal
right-hand man Simon on The Walking Dead,
is a classic "that guy."
You know you've seen him in… something…
somewhere… but you can't just quite put
your finger on it.
So where exactly have you seen that beautiful
mustache before?
Here's why Simon from The Walking Dead looks
so familiar.
Mail Order Bride
Ogg's official screen debut came in a cameo
in the 1999 romcom flop Giving It Up, and
he followed that with a guest appearance on
an episode of Law & Order in 2000.
But his first major role came in the 2003
mob comedy Mail Order bride, which featured
Danny Aiello and Sopranos alum Vincent Pastore
alongside Ogg in a movie The New York Times
called "a strained, incoherent farce."
"Find the broad."
"Broad?"
"Yeah… a broad."
"A… a broad?"
Hey, everyone has to start somewhere.
Grand Theft Auto V
After more than a decade toiling away in bit
roles and bad films like Mail Order Bride,
Ogg finally got his big break in 2013 by switching
mediums.
He wound up being cast to do voicework and
motion capture for the hit video game Grand
Theft Auto V. Ogg played the fan-favorite,
bank-robbing meth-chef Trevor Philips, one
of the game's three main characters.
And he was pretty gratified that fans seemed
to love the result of his work.
He told Buzzfeed, "I have been so thrilled
that the GTA fans have responded so positively
to the performance.
They have enjoyed his impulsive, psychopathic
nature but have reveled in his humor."
"Hey there, Wade."
"Did you meet Debra?"
"Ooh, interesting lady."
"I should probably go say, 'Hi.'"
"I wouldn't…"
Seems that Ogg doesn't keep his unique brand
of insanity restricted to video games, though.
"I wanna do something else, move on to the
next thing.
Probably zombies."
Unforgettable
CBS cop drama Unforgettable, which followed
the daily exploits of a detective with photographic
memory, managed to get canceled three times
— but not before Ogg popped up as sleazy
receptionist Larry Yablonski in the episode
"Day of the Jackie."
Wearing an open shirt over a string vest and
sporting a wild mess of greasy hair, this
is the first time the Canadian character actor
showcased the kind of unkempt crazy that Walking
Dead fans would later love to hate.
Person of Interest
Ogg made another cameo on a CBS procedural
when he popped up as an angry barfly in a
season three episode of Person of Interest.
Luckily for Ogg's character, the authorities
happen to already be in the bar because the
sailor he's fighting has been tagged as a
potential victim of an upcoming crime, so
Ogg managed to get off without too bad a beatdown.
​Broad City
Ogg made a memorable guest appearance in Comedy
Central's Broad City in 2014.
After stars Ilana Glazer and Abbi Jacobson
manage to get locked out of their apartment,
they call for a locksmith and receive a lot
more than they bargained for when Ogg shows
up.
"Yolanda"
"Mmm, Yolanda.
So where is it you sleep?"
"What?"
"Which apartment's yours?"
Even though the guest appearance lasted just
a couple minutes, Ogg told The Calgary Herald
that he still gets recognized at airports
for the role of Creepy Locksmith.
Murdoch Mysteries
Based on the series of novels by British-Canadian
author Maureen Jennings, Murdoch Mysteries
explores crime in 20th-century Ontario through
the eyes of detective William Murdoch.
Ogg turned up on the show in Season 8 episode
"Glory Days," trimming down his handlebar
to a respectable shortness to play Bat Masterson,
a legendary frontier lawman who's tracked
infamous bandits Butch Cassidy and the Sundance
Kid to Toronto.
Despite being a proud Canadian, Ogg played
Masterson as a brash American unimpressed
by law enforcement north of the border, something
he told Dorkshelf he played up on purpose
to prove a point.
"So many people come up to me and say, 'There
is no difference between Canadians and Americans.'
Well, I disagree."
"Where are your guns?"
"We don't carry guns.
North of the border, we rely on our wits."
"Ohh.
Fat lot of good your wits just did us."
Better Call Saul
Another of AMC's shows that Ogg has worked
on, Better Call Saul has evolved from a Breaking
Bad spinoff into a show more than capable
of standing on its own two feet.
Star Bob Odenkirk is the linchpin of the prequel's
success, but he's given ample help by the
show's supporting cast, in particular Jonathan
Banks, who plays ex-cop Mike.
And in a memorable scene from season one,
Ogg got to be on the receiving end of a short
and painful life lesson from Mike.
Man, that's a tough way to make a living.
The Escort
Dark indie romance The Escort is the story
of two sex addicts brought together by a mutually
beneficial arrangement — a down-and-out
journalist in need of a good story and a Stanford-educated
prostitute in need of protection from her
clients.
One of those clients?
Yup.
It's Ogg.
This time around, the Oggster actually backs
down before getting punched, smacked, or beaten.
Who says an old Ogg can't learn new tricks?
Westworld
We saw a lot of Steven Ogg in Westworld.
Not a lot in terms of screen time, but a lot
of Ogg himself, as the actor shot scenes naked
for HBO's hit sci-fi series about robotic
hosts programmed to entertain guests in an
Old West themed amusement park.
His character, Rebus, is one such host, a
villainous cowboy who plays a major part in
a narrative involving fellow host Dolores
Abernathy.
Old Spice ads
In 2016 Ogg began portraying the so-called
King of Products Bob Giovanni in an advertising
campaign for the "Hardest Working Collection"
range, a new series of deodorant from retro
men's groomer Old Spice.
The company devised a tongue-in-cheek plan
to go back to the days when it offered a money-back
guarantee if Old Spice wasn't up for the job,
resurrecting its 1-800-PROVE-IT hotline and
launching some hilariously bad parody ads
starring Ogg.
"So men can focus on other, more important
things."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!